getting into the hospital and then
everything was just a blade
when Leanne White's 12 year old daughter
Ava was stabbed to death in 2021 it was
a crime that shocked and appalled the
nation her killer was just 14 years old
now a campaigner against knife crime
Leanne welcomes a pilot scheme to allow
police to stop and search adults who've
previously been convicted of carrying
bladed or offensive weapons
but she thinks it needs to Target
younger offenders I think they should be
it on as young as 12. we now 12 year
olds are commit amazes we know 12 year
olds are being arrested with blazers
Blazers articles Ava's mayor that I was
14. maybe if these Powers were launched
sailia and either being stopped and said
Ava might not have been made and that
knife might have been to off the street
that nice
merseyside is one of four police forces
taking part in a two-year trial of the
use of serious violence reduction orders
or svros their civil orders that can be
placed on over 18s only who've been
convicted of an offense involving a
bladed or offensive weapon they give
police the power to stop and search
something that's always been a
controversial law enforcement technique
stop and search is incredibly traumatic
and harmful I mean imagine being
every time you walk down your local high
road or on your way to school you're
being stopped and searched by police
it's incredibly humiliating and
ultimately it's not effective merseyside
police says the new powers will enable a
more proactive approach for repeat
offenders and will help protect those
most vulnerable being drawn into
exploitation by criminal gangs
nine eight providing free gym access is
just one way that Paul Bentley hopes to
steer young people towards the right
path he sets up the no more knives
campaign in Liverpool 10 years ago
I think it's a really good idea to
succeed people for weapons that cook to
kill children by all means and ambition
is to say no it's not a good idea I
think most people would be serious to
say it's an invasion of privacy
you can't tell these people who've lost
the children that it's an invasion of
privacy they're just trying to carry out
a law that might prevent
and then we can do a bit of healing
one thing the anti-knife campaigners and
the police agree on is that tackling
knife crime can only be effective with a
multi-agency approach that involves
children parents Educators and
communities
Fraser mode Sky News Liverpool